well Oh Dave Ramsey this is your old
buddy John O'Leary delighted to be with
you today and celebrating 25 years of
impacting lives all around the country
and all around the world your best days
my friend and your greatest impact
remain in front of you god bless you
continue boldly and the best is yet to
come Dave thank you my friend
John Larry's a good scholar is a good
man a wonderful world-class speaker an
inspiring aspiring story we are
celebrating our 25th anniversary and
we're doing that by taking a segment
ever so often this summer one of the
segments not entire shows my entire day
so we might take one but but most of the
time we're doing a little segment here
there and just reminiscing a little bit
if you didn't know back 15-20 years ago
we used to do themed hours and one of
the females we did was from a saying
that I have I don't remember where I
picked it up I probably stole it from
someone most of my sayings are stolen
from someone but I always tell folks
that when you do something stupid with
money and you lose money I call that
stupid tax and I have paid a lot of
stupid tax in my life and most of you
have paid some stupid X some of you more
than others I've paid it with zeroes on
the end so we started doing stupid tax
hours what's something funny that you've
had happen or something is so
ridiculously crazy that you did to lose
money that you paid stupid tax that it's
entertaining for the rest of us and so
James Child's Blake Thompson our
producers I went through some of the old
archives these are old these are 15 20
year old clips from the stupid tax theme
our the first one I remember each one of
these that's what's weird I remember
this guy this is work because I was
cracking up the whole time he's doing
this so here's the first one my ex-wife
or the $3.00 check it bounced once she
sent it back through and it bounced
twice $45 for three dollars so she could
have paid in cash
she repeatedly bounced the check
unbelievable $45 for a $3 check now some
of you have done that some of you've
written in college especially I've seen
people write a check for under a
all are you seeing people do that or
under $2 Kelly's looking like she might
have done that she's got that look I did
it I did it I mean because we used to
write checks back in the day for
everything and because we didn't have
any B sub products to debit cards or
anything like that so we're doing the
stupid text theme our and this was
probably the well the most popular one
you guys don't have pulled out the
funniest one and that was the one you
don't have the one I guess y'all
couldn't find it the guy paid for his
wife to have breast implants and goes
home and catches her in an affair with
her boss beats up the boss gets thrown
in jail gets a divorce and had to pay
the payments on the breast that he never
got the benefit of because it gets the
boy that one was the most popular people
laughed about that for a decade but we
don't have that clip so I had to recap
that one but this one was I guess the
number two funniest and most popular
right here the monkey
I bought a monkey you didn't I did a
spotted nose guenon because a potted
nose gwinin yes it's a type of monkey it
was a beautiful monkey sounds like a
girl I went out with in hospital every
time I try to kiss her hugging my wife
that monkey would try to punch my wife
with its little fist and bottom line is
my wife she just didn't care for that
too much so he ends up I think he paid
you cut it out he paid something like
2,500 bucks for the monkey and end up
selling it for like a hundred bucks to
get rid of it he takes a two thousand
dollar plus loss on the spotted nose
Glennon
now that's weird that was funny enough
we laughed about it for days is why I
remember it but it's 15 or 20 years ago
so and then we talked about this the
other day with Blake but there's been I
think only two times that I can remember
where I got the giggles on something I
started laughing at something that
someone said on the air or something
that happened around the studio either
one so hard that I couldn't recover and
we had to go
take the shoto commercial because i was
giggling like a 13 year old girl at the
school lunch table you know I could not
get it back and just lost it and this
was one of those I was thinking of the
advisability of putting in a pay phone
instead of my regular phone service
because for 800 dollars you can get a
pay phone joke that you have to pay for
the phone line still I had a pay phone
yeah if you picked if you don't have the
phone I had to the phone you're not
going to dolled up okay well that's what
I wanted to find out if there was a hole
in this air gap and so it went from
there downhill yeah start asking who's
gonna put money on it my family who's
gonna get money out of it me where's
your family get the money to put in it
for me look how confuse here are you
making money oh the things we've done on
the air over the years all right I think
we got one more clip I don't remember
this only one of the four I didn't
remember and this guy just used the
stupid tax line beautifully from what I
hear so let's hear it Dave I appreciate
you taking my call oh I have to tell you
that when they were handing out stupid
tax I went through the buffet line I've
been there done the stupid tax buffet
line yeah we've all done that very cool
fun stuff now on July 13th we want you
to tune in and be with us Laura Johnson
will be with us Laura and now runs all
the video channel and all the stuff for
the YouTube channel and all of that
she's one of our senior producers here
but for many years she was the phone
screener and then the phone screen our
Associate Producer my goodness were
probably well over a decade matter of
fact when she first came she had not
been married her name was May's we
called her Lora Mae's the amazing one
back in the day we never called you that
Kelly sad well Kelly
annual we should come up with something
that rhymes with that that means amazing
right yeah yeah you work it's July 27th
okay as opposed to as opposed to what
says on this look
piece of paper in front of me okay Oh
July 13th would be today yeah oh yeah
there's that okay something no a day it
is
this is bad all right so Laura will be
with us on 2020 seventh which is not
today and she apparently was talked
about when we first hired her as a phone
screener that's not a real pretty story
so I'm interested to see what perversion
is to come on the air and actually share
with three million people but so what
we're doing is we're going back through
the old days and talking about how
really how funny it all was how fun at
all was and it's always been the same
you know all we've done is help people
we've always answered questions back in
those days you heard the accident was a
little thicker southern accent and I had
to go I didn't have to but I chose to
get have a voice coach come in from a
broadcast school and teach me how to
enunciate my words with a little less
accident I've still got a pretty good
hillbilly accident and I'm proud of it I
didn't want it all to go away it's part
of my heritage and part of who I am but
we you get those old tapes out you can
hear it it's a little thicker there and
a little different the same is true with
all the behind the scenes stuff we had
to learn to do things differently and
had we started with reel-to-reel tapes
for the commercials back 25 years ago
and these little things called cart
machines that are a little version of an
eight-track looking tape that we played
all the spots on and all the bits were
on those cart machines and all and in
those days a music business you had a
each song was on a cart and you know
cart rack and you reach and pull on
those late tracks and play play the
Eagles or play whatever your part or
whoever you were going to play in those
days and that's how the DJ's did it back
then so this is after the LP era
obviously 25 years ago in 1992 and we
get started so well revisit some of
those things and just reminisce a little
bit here there as we go along through
this summer because it was just the
other day that we actually the 29th of
June was actually the technical date
that was the day that we started the
show
25 years ago so we're using this summer
up into the fall to celebrate that and
again reminisce a little bit you'll get
the benefit of that or if you want to
call it that oh there you go nice well
done a little heart and that stuff used
to be the bump music is the music I like
yeah that's that's what made a
difference so this is the Dave Ramsey
show hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]